[Music]
welcome to project Pannonia a
collaboration involving eleven history
youtubers all doing videos on various
events in the history of the Pannonian
Basin from the Roman era all the way to
Hungary's involvement in world war ii
and what better way to start off this
collab and with the people that created
the province that gave these gas lines
the name of Pannonia the romans prior to
the roman conquest of Pannonia we don't
really know much about the area or the
people living in it how are looking
through archaeology and very brief
mentions of the area and Latin and Greek
sources we can gather small clues as to
what happened at the beginning of the
4th century BCE there was a big celtic
invasion of Pannonia which coincided
with the celtic invasion of Italy this
invasion was mostly centered around
going down the Danube and drama rivers
the people that inhabited the area
before the Celts were mostly the
illyrian tribe of benoni when they get
pushed out by the Celts this tribe moved
south settling around the Sava river
however despite this resettlement in the
3rd century BCE the Pannonia eventually
succumbed to a Celtic invasion by tribe
coats cordis tea during this time
Eastern Pannonia and Transylvania was
mostly controlled by the dashians a
subgroup of the three Shen's but that
didn't stop the Celts migrating there as
well for the next couple of centuries
the Pannonian area underwent large
Celtic ization with the - Ian lands
having a mixed - Ian / Celtic culture
and discord east sea' controlled benoni
having a mixed illyrian / celtic culture
however even though the entire area was
under the Celtic influence this is not
to say it was all unified there were
many bickering Celtic tribes that didn't
seem to be the best of friends some of
the most notable ones were the Bowie
tribal Alliance who were driven out of
northern Italy by the Romans and 193 and
settled in northern Pannonia the
touristy inhabiting Western Pannonia the
Scottish Deerhound the Sava river and of
course the Celtic dashians in eastern
Pannonia and transylvania in around ad a
281 BC the Scottish see which were
struggling to keep control over the
Pannonian for several decades now were
decisively defeated by a Roman
Lucius Cornelius Kippy OSE Atticus no
not that one his great-grandson yeah
that one after this defeat discord ist's
he disappear being replaced by their
captives the Pannonia also starting
during this time until around 45 BC the
three shanking but a beast ax solidified
the Dyson lands and conquered all of
Pannonia east of the Danube the stasi
and pressure from the east newly
liberated illyrian pressure from the
south and roman pressure from the west
destroyed the larger Celtic political
entities that existed up until now and
the Celtic control Pannonia became very
fragmented when exactly the basin became
part of the Roman Empire is very much
debated but most likely due to the now
fragmented political nature of the area
it was a gradual process than on the
reign of Augustus from around thirty
five to nine BCE it was also during this
time that the dust in control of eastern
Pannonia slowly withered away as the
kingdom struggled to keep together after
the death of Buda Bista in eleven BC the
frontier of the Roman Empire was
officially set all the way to the Danube
River and then two years later this new
land was incorporated into the province
of Illyricum however certain areas of
this frontier weren't very loyal to the
Empire and the Romans didn't really have
any major control in the countryside
this along with the local resentment
against the Romans resulted in the great
illyrian revolt in 6ee however does
mainly involve just illyrians in
southern Pannonia as the celts for the
north seemed to have been content with
the roman rule when the revolt was
finally subdued by Tiberius and
Germanicus three years later Illyricum
was deemed to be too large to govern
effectively and so it was divided up it
was also in the early 1st century that
the cement en tribe of via Xia's
migrated into the area east of the
Danube whether the Romans invited them
to come here and act as a buffer between
them and the dashians or they migrated
on their own using the fracturing of the
Dacia kingdom to their benefit is still
debated
what's also debated is the origin of the
name Pannonia but in my opinion and most
likely comes from an illyrian word which
meant swampy land or wetland which makes
sense as the Pannonian Basin is just a
giant tributary for the Danubian
and illyrians were the original
inhabitants of this area
[Music]
now Roman Pannonia didn't stretch across
the entire Pannonian Basin it
encompassed only the area of the basin
west and south of the Danube power with
that said this Roman province name
started to be used to refer to the
entire geographical location of the
basin and the medieval period hence why
we called this entire area the Pannonian
Basin or plain today when it came to
administrative matters Pannonia actually
underwent several changes throughout the
Roman period first being the province of
Pannonia then dividing into two Pannonia
Stan enter Ford and back into one etc
however I'm going to be mostly skipping
over these divisions referring to
Pannonia as a whole so from the Year 9
at the end of the illyrian revolt
Pannonia was finally firmly under Roman
control and it will stay like this until
the 5th century to put this into
perspective Romans controlled Pannonia
for longer than USA has been a country
plus about 200 years more with this much
time of Roman rule in the area it is
undeniable that they left their mark on
these lands the first major change that
came with the Romans was the creation of
cities yester where population
establishments like Celtic epitomes
before the Roman arrival but the
majority of these were more of a
fortified village rather than an actual
city however as Roman colonists arrived
combined with the slow Latinization of
the native population Pannonia gradually
became more urbanized this urbanization
was also helped in part by the creation
of the Roman road network which the
Romans built mainly for an ease of
supply to the legions stationed in
Pannonia along with building up these
major roads and cities three of which
are capital cities today do Romans also
did some engineering work on the Danube
this is because some parts of the Danube
back then were very treacherous for
boats and sailing on it could be very
costly for supply fleets but the Romans
remedied this making the river much more
safer to sail on and also establish the
first note that nubian fleet stationed
in contemn this fleet was used to not
only supply the cities along the river
but also to protect the border as Danube
was the border the Romans also brought
winemaking to the region established
numerous bath houses and overall brought
drastic economic development to the area
when it came to legions stationed and
Pannonia
the amount and type of legions changed
over time but from the Hadrian era all
the way to Late Antiquity there were
roughly six main ones the tenth Legion
geminus station in Vindobona today's
Vienna the 14th Legion Jimena station in
car Mountain today's patron El Carmen
tomb the first legion a dietrich station
and brig ato today's camaron the second
legion a dietrich station a quinn come
today's budapest the fourth Legion
Flavia station and singi dunam today's
Belgrade and lastly the seventh Legion
Claudia station and women Akuma's you
may have noticed the area between
budapest and bill grade had a very large
empty border without any legions
protecting it this was mainly due to the
very ineffective way that legions were
assigned to various Roman provinces but
since it's very boring to talk about
bureaucracy we can just conclude that
the Romans made a mistake due to this
mistake however the second and fourth
Legion had to protect a much larger
border than for example the 10th 14 and
1st legions this resulted in the fact
that the 2nd Legion was by far the most
active Legion of Pannonia having to go
on many expeditionary campaigns within
and outside of the Roman borders to
secure peace in the region while this
was happening the fourth Legion was
always transferred to Budapest to
protect from any rear attacks this high
activity of the 2nd Legion and Pannonia
along with the fact that it was
stationed in today's Budapest were some
of the reasons why we decided to go with
the symbol of the 2nd Legion the Pegasus
for our project Pannonia Kolob the
relative peace that was had by the
Romans and Pannonia was broken in 85
this was because at this point the Dacia
Kingdom which was fragmented ever since
the death of barista finally United
again and started to hold raiding
expeditions across the Danube
most of these weren't held in Pannonia
but in museum or south how our Pannonian
legions did play a vital role in this
conflict the romans eventually brokered
a peace with the dashians but romans
being romans knowing this one class
started to build up many auxilary
fortifications along the danube getting
ready for the eventual second war with
the dashians this war came in 101 ending
with the roman victory in 102 but peace
didn't last as the 3rd a.cian war start
105 with the Romans again winning in 106
but this time they made sure there won't
be a fourth Dacia in war they subdued
the entire area and incorporated it into
the Roman Empire as a new province the
Yezidis during this time were doing a
bit of flip-flopping with their
alliances between the dashians and
Romans however in the end these wars
resulted in a much more direct control
by the Romans over them becoming a
client state between 117 and 123
from there for about 50 plus years
Pannonian slipped in relative peace
making wine bathing socializing trading
and whatever else Romans did however
this all came to an end during the
outbreak of the Mark Romanek Wars and
162 these wars were the first signs of
large-scale migrations happening outside
of the Roman borders and many tribes
that were already living near the Roman
border had nowhere to go but across that
border and so Pannonia got invaded first
by Germanic tribes from the north and
then by the Yazidis from the east
however these invasions managed to be
repelled by the Romans after which the
Romans launched a counter-attack against
the es es all while yet another Germanic
army crossed from the north devastating
Vienna and marching all the way south to
north and Italy before being defeated
after this the Romans undertook a
large-scale offensive north which proved
successful and a Roman Emperor Marcus
Aurelius even considered creating buffer
provinces north of Pannonia to protect
from any other future attacks but this
did not happen as he died in 180 and his
successor Commodus didn't follow through
on these victories
Commodus however did set out on another
campaign against the osseous scoring a
quick victory at this point it is safe
to say that the easiest were firmly
under Roman control however what kind of
control this was is unknown this
combined with frequent small rebellions
and Wars by the es es throughout the
next century or so means that even
though they surely were controlled by
the Romans the area east of the Danube
was never fully incorporated into the
empire as for example Dacia was however
one argument against this could be the
fact that the construction of the Devils
dike started around the later half of
the second century probably used as part
of the Roman limes hence we can conclude
the Romans that consider this area as
part of their empire even with all the
frequency as against rebellions after
the mark romantic Wars the Pannonian
area became settled by a lot of Germanic
people that were either allowed to
settle here or use the confusion of the
wars to cross the border or even where
the remnants of the defeated Germanic
armies however as it often does during
the next couple of decades of roughly
piece these Germanic people get slowly
latinized just as the Celts had before
them the next major step in Roman
Pannonian history came during the
Christianization of the Roman Empire
it seems that outside of CMU most of
Pannonia was very much starch li pagan
until constantine came to power after
which almost comically quickly the
Pannonian people especially the higher
class converted to Christianity with
Fagan burials being found increasingly
rarely after early fourth century it was
also during Constantine's era that the
Vandals showed up on the fringes of the
Pannonian border being pushed there by
the Goths Constantine allowed the
Vandals to set on the right bank of the
Danube most likely to control the
Troublesome es es it was also at this
point that the devil's dyke reached its
highest extent meaning that Romans were
probably hoping to keep control the
entire Pannonian plain for a while
however all things must come to an end
and the roughly four hundred and forty
year long Roman control of Pannonia was
no different
by the late roman period the border
regions had a constant activity of enter
tribal wars migrations alliances etc
this combined with wavering internal
Rome and politics meant that it was
clear the Roman hold and Pannonia wasn't
going to last
there were several tribes like the
vandals goths etc that attacked Pannonia
and the late fourth and early fifth
century but the Romans still managed to
keep hold of the area until the arrival
of the Huns it is known that the Huns
controlled much of Pannonia by 437 but
how and when exactly did they conquered
it is unknown but most likely starting
around 420 they probably did it the same
way the Romans conquered Pannonia well
over 400 years earlier it was a gradual
taking of control by the hands with
interest first Roman expeditions trying
to hold on to whatever they could it is
also interesting to learn that the area
of specially southern Pannonia and
Malaysia was given back and forth
between the Western and Eastern Roman
empires as both sides clearly didn't
want to deal with the hunting raids the
official Roman control of Pannonia is
dated to be until 447 when the eastern
Roman Empire finally gave up the claims
to the Pannonian lands but as we
discussed the Romans didn't really
control the area for decades at this
point
that is where I will conclude my video
about ramen Pannonia because it's time
for Epimetheus to take the torch and
talk about the huns also check out the
last video in the project Pannonia
collab done by his story Graff who's
talking about the Hungarian involvement
in World War 2 if you liked my video
please consider subscribing and stick
around for history